[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VAIS: Let's say
you want to build an app.
Not just any app, but
a serverless, scalable,
mobile-thinking,
analytical IoT app.
If you do a quick
Google search, you
will get 1.2 billion
results on how to do this.
So where do you start?
My name is Natalie Vais,
and I'm a Product Manager
on Cloud Firestore.
Today, I want to talk to you
about building amazing apps,
specifically, how
to build globally
scalable apps with
Cloud Firestore.
If you're starting a new
project from scratch,
and you want to
build it yourself,
you'll likely have to think
about a couple of things--
number one, setting up
a database, number two,
creating some kind of API layer
on top of it so you can make
queries from your clients.
And that probably means, third,
creating an authentication
service to make sure
users can only access
data they're supposed to.
And then lastly,
making sure your data
syncs with your
local results which
are probably being stored in
a completely separate client
database.
Now, just make sure it works
across multiple platforms.
It can easily handle things
like spotty network connections.
Simple, right?
As soon as your app goes viral--
fingers crossed for you--
all of a sudden,
you have to worry
about scaling, high
availability, and disaster
recovery strategies.
And you'll probably need to hire
more people to manage it, too.
Or you can just use
Cloud Firestore.
Cloud Firestore is
a fully managed,
serverless, NoSQL document
database purpose-built
for solving some of the toughest
problems of mobile web and IoT
app development today.
In many ways, it's
more than a database.
It's an entire back
end for your apps.
To create Firestore,
we learned from two
other popular
databases at Google--
Firebase Realtime Database
and Cloud Datastore--
usage patterns have shifted
since those architectures
were designed some 7 to 10
years ago, respectively.
So we took a close look
at the developer wish
list for each of these
to inform the products.
You can think of
Firestore as the best
of both of these worlds.
Cloud Firestore
handles all the things
that you don't want to think
about when you're developing
a mobile app, so you can really
focus on your core business.
The first thing to know is
that Cloud Firestore is fully
supported in the Firebase SDKs.
This includes web,
iOS, and Android,
so you can access data
directly from these clients.
This works in conjunction with
Firebase Auth and Security
Rules.
And those things
allow you to control
who has access to read and
modify data on the server.
There's that Auth layer we
mentioned at the beginning.
You wouldn't believe how
normal it has become for people
to look at their apps
when there is absolutely
no chance of connectivity.
A person checks their phone an
average of 80 times in a day,
so it's becoming increasingly
common for people
to expect our apps to work
offline and across devices.
With Cloud Firestore,
the client libraries
already come with full
support for offline mode.
The SDK handles conflict
resolution on-device
and syncs up with the
server when you reconnect.
Because we built Cloud Firestore
with a serverless architecture,
you don't have to worry
about provisioning, capacity
planning, scaling,
or maintenance.
There are servers
distributed across the world,
just not ones that
you have to manage.
All of this is taken
care of by the system.
Scaling is automatic and
happens as an online operation.
Say goodbye to
maintenance windows.
On top of that, Cloud Firestore
is built for the Cloud.
That means it's replicated
across zones and regions
depending on how you
choose to configure it.
In this year alone, and as part
of going generally available,
we added 10 new locations
to Cloud Firestore.
Replication across
data centers is really
one of those things you want
to outsource if you can.
It becomes complicated
quickly and has
a huge overhead for ops teams.
With this replication,
you get five nines
SLA for multi-region
and a four nines
SLA for regional deployments.
This is one of the highest
availability services we offer.
All of this lets you focus
on your core business
and leaves the infrastructure
to Google Cloud,
which is our core business.
With over 1 million
databases created already,
Cloud Firestore has
seen a huge diversity
of workloads already deployed
within our customer base.
The unifying themes among
these workloads include--
number one, the
need for data access
even when connectivity
lapses; number two,
scalability for many
users across platforms;
and number three, the
ability to move quickly
from prototype to production.
And that's Cloud Firestore--
your auto-syncing, auto-scaling
database in the Cloud.
Give it a try, and find out why
it's the most discussed cloud
database on Stack Overflow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]